so as going through here whoa
wait a minute
oh damn that's old ass mario benji and i
didn't even notice that the first time
around what
oh cool
[Music]
hello there reject nation obligatory
terrible keon reeves impression because
we got a second trailer for the matrix
resurrections today people so uh yeah we
were filming pretty late hawkeye
midnight shoot i sent john home around
five in the morning after dealing with a
couple blocks i finally got hawkeye up
around seven a.m was gonna go to bed and
then bam matrix resurrections trailer
two bunch of notifications on my youtube
app i was like well the matrix is my
favorite movie of all time tied with
terminator 2. i have to check this out i
just it's it's a must i am very much
looking forward to this i'm a tat i have
some concerns just because you know the
matrix is my favorite movie and the fact
that i'm one of the few people who
proudly declares that he actually
greatly enjoys the sequels i still have
some of my concerns with uh what's
coming up but i'm still very much
looking forward to it and if anything
the thing that i'm mainly concerned
about is that this is coming out a week
after spider-man no way home so i'm kind
of concerned that spider-man at home is
going to completely overshadow this at
the box office let's see what we got
it's only a minute long this second
trailer is subtitled deja vu let's get
into action
[Music]
deja vu is usually a glitch in the
matrix
it happens when they change something
the one
how interesting
[Music]
jonathan gruff
whoa
gotta slow some of this down there i use
old code
to mirror something new
why use old maybe this isn't the story
we think it is
fascinating
[Music]
what i really appreciate about this
trailer in particular though the first
trailer the official one seemed to
really do something that was reflective
of like all the nostalgia seem to be
leaning mainly on the first movie while
there are some characters that you're
looking at and i heard the mayor of
indian is going to be returning who was
in matrix reloaded in revolutions the
first trailer seemed to really hone in
primarily on the first movie kind of
making it feel like semi reboots and my
remake i have a lot of faith in lana
wachowski and the vision of this
franchise as a whole what i loved about
this one was that it seemed to actually
be acknowledging the sequels where i
felt like the first trailer really left
that in the background a lot there's
only a couple of things that feel
indicative of the sequel so actually
getting some imagery here and having
this whole theme of deja vu and the
marketing for this film as much as we're
looking at new imagery that does look
beautiful to behold it still is just
likening towards the films from before
it starts having me
question a couple of things like what
will be the overall theme of this movie
you know from the trilogy as a whole
there's been a whole bunch of
philosophical themes that they have
explored all the way down to creation
identity
religion existentialism capitalism and
like there's a whole lot they've they've
dealt with that i have thoroughly
enjoyed and i know this is called
resurrections and the marketing to say
the least has seemed to be quite overt
with that resurrection theme so much to
the point that you kind of feel like
this subtitle should be called matrix
rebooted the idea that they're going
over all three of the movies here in
this trailer makes me wonder are we
going to be doing kind of like this this
hodgepodge of all three movies in one
what's going to be the runtime of this
film so i'm very curious to see how this
all ultimately progresses there are a
couple of key moments i do want to go
through here really quick though because
you know they have that line in here
that says they're using why use old code
to create something new that is that's a
great question because i i believe if my
sleep deprived memory is serving me
correct is that in the matrix reloaded
uh the architect this should be the
seventh version of the matrix that the
architecture is talking when neo is
saying that the ideally what the how the
program should be run is that the one
that neo should return to the source
line for like a temporary disbandment i
think is the word i'm probably getting
that rom of the code that he carries
then after that he's supposed to select
the certain number of individuals to
rebuild zion and if he doesn't comply
then that leads to the extermination of
everyone in the matrix and every one of
zion so essentially the extinction of
the human race
as we saw the events did not transpire
that way in the matrix trilogy so it
looks like to me i mean let me pull up
some of this footage here you see they
have this line here about uh why use the
old code to create something new and it
sounds like the whole goal of the
machines that has always been to gain
control you had a virus like agent smith
one of the machines built into the
matrix who essentially still wanted
control and that's kind of the
impression i'm getting from the jonathan
groff character
so as going through here whoa
wait a minute
oh damn that's old-ass mario benji and i
didn't even notice that the first time
around
what oh cool
oh that's okay so he's gonna come back
and there's an older program so i guess
he ages in this program but then here
these shots of all them so you have like
morpheus from matrix one i think that is
neo from matrix revolutions
this is trinity from matrix reloaded and
then you have jonathan groff who to me
just reads like a program from the
matrix who probably wants control of it
in some way the indication i'm getting
is like using the old code in some
grander equation that i cannot possibly
conjure up here in the moment but
somehow is using the old code
resurrecting people like trinity and neo
essentially reworking an older version
of the matrix so he can establish his
own version of the matrix that's just
sort of the impression that i've been
getting from the trailers because any
talk you get with him seems very ominous
and like just a dude you can't trust so
like this shot's a little bit confusing
and weird to me because this would imply
that trinity is just a program and then
the matrix but then we had a shot in
another trailer that showed that she was
indeed being resurrected in in the real
world i don't know you have this shot
here later of uh neo
in the real world so he does get
unplugged at some point uh from behind
this person kind of looks like jessica
henwick yeah i mean you do see neo gets
unplugged at some point in the movie
maybe it's to find
trinity in the real world and put her
back into
have that little marriage with the
program i don't know i don't know like
quite evidently the humans and the
machines have not found peace with each
other i mean if you look at this shot
right here this seems straight out like
a sci-fi war epic battle you have like
laser blast sounds going on in this one
shot and this shot to me is so
fascinating too they they seem like
they're mind-controlled i mean they're
obviously mind-controlled but we haven't
seen that in the matrix trilogy yet i
mean we've seen where you know agents
can hop into other people's bodies and
what not take over so you know if
they're plugged in they can essentially
be a threat the ai seems to really be
controlling them just to try to take
down
neo so yeah i mean i got a lot of
questions but that's part of the fun of
the matrix trilogy or the matrix
franchise as a whole is the what the
[ __ ] quality to it and trying to
understand the the deeper motives and
deeper understandings of the whole
process but i'll say something that
feels kind of like a nostalgia trip for
mayton going down matrix trilogy memory
lane feels like it's not going to be a
pleasant trip down memory lane that it
seems like it's going to be combining
elements of psychological trauma from
the character of thomas anderson aka neo
and then of course whatever commentary
because the commentary and reloaded in
revolutions is different from the
commentary in the first matrix so i'm
really curious what the main commentary
is gonna be in this one is is it gonna
be something about reboots it this seems
like this could be
the matrix movie that is the most
meta
of any of the matrix films i'm looking
forward to it man all right i think he's
gonna be [ __ ] awesome
i'm gonna watch this in the theaters but
guys what'd you think about this leave
your thoughts down below are you
enjoying the deja vu memory lane
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and hey we'll catch you guys soon
you